hey I'm not a hippie I'm not right-wing
anything you've read about me is mostly
[ __ ] so hopefully you'll form your
own opinions based on my talk today this
talk sometimes takes an hour so I'm told
the people at Stanford are really smart
so I'm gonna go really fast
assuming you're all really quick studies
and that'll save more time for Q&A so I
do think we need new paradigms for the
way we think about business and the way
we think about capitalism some day and
historians are gonna look back in the
twentieth century and they're gonna see
that a great war was fought between two
different philosophies of economics
socialism and capitalism capitalism won
that competition every place that it had
that competition whether it be the
United States versus the Soviet Union or
South Korea versus North Korea or in any
East Germany versus West Germany etc
cetera Center however it did not capture
the minds of the intellectuals or the
hearts of the people capitalism was
still greatly mistrusted and
corporations who I believe are the most
influential institutions of the world or
widely perceived as greedy selfish and
exploitative they're certainly not
worthy of any trust you can see this
very clearly with the deep recession
that we've been into.the the financial
crisis hasn't been demagogued
as a fault of greed and corporations out
of control another example of capitalism
not working and there's been no blame
for bad government policies bad monetary
policy bad regulations and I would argue
that corporations and capitalism have
serious branding problems they are not
branded very well they don't market
themselves very well in the PR side of
things and what I see happening is that
even though capitalism won the battles
in the twenty 20th century that we're
rapidly
back towards more socialism or
progressivism and I'm gonna argue that
there's another way that conscious
leadership conscious business and
conscious capitalism is what we should
be doing so conscious capitalism is
based on four primary principles of
economics secure property rights freedom
of contract freedom of trade and the
rule of law conscious capitalism is
equal to these four primary economic
principles plus conscious business which
leads the question what then is
conscious business conscious business is
based on going in and out in and out
maybe I'll talk it whoa conscious of
business is based on these three primary
principles of enterprise which is what
I'm going to primarily talk about the
enterprise has the potential to have a
higher purpose beyond merely maximizing
profits and shareholder value the
enterprise is managed to optimize value
simultaneously for all of the
interdependent stakeholders and then the
leadership of the organization is
conscious leadership that serves the
enterprise and stakeholders if you go to
a cocktail party and you ask people what
the purpose of a business is do this
experiment sometime you'll find 99% of
the time people will say what do you
mean what the purpose of business's
purpose of business make money everybody
knows that but that's kind of a curious
answer because if you ask what the
purpose of a doctor is people aren't
gonna table everybody knows a purpose of
a doctor's to make money or if you ask
what the purpose of a teacher is no one
says well teachers purpose is to make
money purpose of a doctors to heal
people purpose of a teachers to educate
people purpose of an architect design
buildings why is it that we say the
purpose of a business is to make money
and who defines what the purpose of a
business is anyway
I'll argue that the entrepreneur who
creates the business in the first place
is the one who has the right to define
what the purpose of that business is and
I have known hundreds hundreds of
entrepreneurs in my lifetime and with
only a few exceptions have they told me
that their primary purpose was to make
as much money as possible
they had multiplicity of reasons why
they started their business and sure
they wanted to make money but that
wasn't what was driving them I had the
privilege to meet Bill Gates a year or
so ago and I got to talking about this
and with Bill and believe it or not he
didn't start Microsoft's become the
wealthiest man in the world he was on
fire about software he had a vision of
everyone having their own personal
computer and that was an incredibly
revolutionary idea let me a quick poll
here how many people here have their own
personal computer
that's why Bill Gates is the richest man
in the world because he had a vision
about that and he pursued it with a
single mindedness and a passion and the
rest so to speak his history
entrepreneurs create the original
purpose of business and in the 21st
century entrepreneurs of the conscious
business are also entrepreneurs of
meaning they must determine the meaning
and they must interpret it and they must
explain it and what I found very
interesting is that although the
entrepreneur may create the original
purpose of the business
it's the stakeholders that ultimately
evolve the purpose of the business over
time and these communities of
stakeholders interacting with the
enterprise the businesses purpose
continues to evolve and the businesses
that flourish over the long term will
continue to get to either you can do a
metaphor of higher and higher or deeper
and deeper in terms of the meaning of
what their purpose is to higher levels
of complexity and meaning the great
companies in this world have great
purposes if you think about the
companies that you most admire scratch
the surface and you'll find they
are trying to fulfill a deeper or higher
purpose they're not always completely
conscious of it but it resonates in
their very DNA and stealing from Plato
the deepest purpose is that he was able
to articulate the good the true and the
beautiful I added on heroic these four
categories are sufficient to explain at
the most abstract level what the
potential deeper purpose is that each
business can try to manifest in the
world if you think about a business
that's serving the good or fulfilling
pursuing the good one of my favorite
examples is Southwest Airlines which is
a tremendously very I think very much a
conscious business and definitely is
pursuing a deeper purpose of service to
others Nordstrom's another good example
there in terms of the true think about
how exciting it must be to discover
something that no one has ever known
before that advances humanity and yet
that's what companies like Google have
done or Intel or Genentech those were
three of my favorite examples there how
about the beautiful what's beautiful
have to do with business in a sense a
business that strives for excellence
because excellence is inherently
beautiful
how about Apple their technology is
beautiful I think iPhones IMAX iPods or
beautiful technology Warren Buffett what
he's done with Berkshire Hathaway he's
made investing into something I think is
an art form it's beautiful we talk about
the heroic courage to do what is right
to change and improve the world
Bill Gates at Microsoft and now with the
Gates Foundation Muhammad Yunus with the
Grameen Grameen Bank are two my favorite
examples
I call this the paradox of profits and
best way to understand it's through the
metaphor the analogy of happiness I'm
now old enough to be able to speak with
some Authority about happiness and what
I have found is that happiness is a
byproduct of other things that people
who tell you that the purpose of their
the purpose of their life is to be happy
probably aren't gonna aren't gonna find
it
happiness is a people that are obsessed
with finding their own happiness tend to
be sort of self-involved narcissists and
that's a very bad strategy it does not
lead to ultimate happiness or
fulfillment
rather having a deeper purpose service
striving for excellence growing as a
Hindu individual friendship love
generosity these are the type of virtues
that when practice lead to happiness
similarly I believe the profits are best
realized when they're not made the
primary goal of the business that they
are also a byproduct of deeper purpose
great products and services customer
satisfaction employee happiness and
social environmental responsibility the
metaphors that we use to think about
business are not good metaphors one
going back to Adam Smith and the
Industrial Revolution in terms of
business being like a machine you put in
land labor and capital put it on the
assembly line and do it profit spit out
the Darwinian models of survival of the
fittest war metaphors we're gonna crush
our competitors and roll them up I don't
think those are great metaphors for
really understanding business and they
metaphors do determine how we think
about things we need to be careful in
terms of the metaphors that we use to
think about anything I'm gonna argue
that a good metaphor to use in the 21st
century is that of a complex adaptive
self-organizing system that creates
value for all of the interdependent
constituencies or stakeholders
what is conscious leadership conscious
leadership fulfill the deeper purpose of
the organization create value for the
interdependent stakeholders and to be a
servant leader to the enterprise what I
mean by servant leader it means you're
serving the enterprise and its purpose
you're not there trying to line your own
pockets and see how much money you can
make the true transformative leadership
is serving that organization so adopting
the metaphor of a servant leader is a
very appropriate metaphor creating value
for the entire interdependent system I
will argue today and this is my radical
idea that that will also simultaneously
result in the highest long-term profits
and shareholder value I'm gonna argue
the Whole Foods is a conscious business
there are some other good examples right
here only one I understand really well
from the inside out is Whole Foods so
I'm going to use that as my primary
example here's a simple model that we
use to think about our business it
starts with our mission why we exist
what our deeper purpose is the core
values they're at the center they're at
the heart of everything we do and then
radiating out from that heart like like
spokes on a wheel are the major
interdependent stakeholders the team
members the suppliers the customers the
investors and the community and the
environment
this model is oversimplified because a
web of all those stakeholders
interacting with each other would be
more appropriate but I haven't figured
out how to model that in a simplistic
way it but simply when you allow these
stakeholders to when you manage to
create value for all of them at the same
time you end up in a in an upward spiral
so instant this is a circle but a more
appropriate metaphor be to show this in
an upward spiral of continued value
creation so conscious leadership focuses
on synergies not on the trade-offs I'm
heading off a question that I will get
what about the trade-offs and the
conflicts that you have between the
various stakeholders the more you
give the employees the less money you
have to give the investors the more
money you give away to not-for-profit
organizations then the less money you
have for shareholder value the higher
you pay your workers the less money
there will be for investors and so forth
and so on as if Hobbs war against the
war against all against all is in in
play here that there's this ongoing
struggle between the stakeholders the
conscious leader sees the
interdependencies and sees the
relationships if you look for trade offs
you can find them if you look for
synergies you can find them the
conscious leader looks for the synergies
looks for the strategies that will
create value simultaneously for all of
the interdependent stakeholders once
creative mind does not need to think in
terms of a zero-sum game I win you lose
you lose I win we can create win-win-win
strategies that is the beauty of
capitalism that is its potential to
create value for all of the ones that
are voluntarily exchanging with the
business the human mind is infinitely
creative beginning to think this way
creates new mental pathways and
unleashes human creativity in unexpected
ways it will be the creative
entrepreneurs and the conscious
capitalists who will solve the problems
that the world faces in the 21st century
it's going to be that individual
creativity applied collaboratively
through enterprise that will solve most
of the world's problems what is whole
food Steve his purpose I used to believe
for many years Whole Foods the deepest
purpose was the good we're in a service
business were to serve other people and
then as I did this talk around Whole
Foods and I would instead of giving the
answer I would pull the team members I
would say well I'd explain the four
deepest highest purposes and then I take
a poll and I'd ask the team members to
tell me what do you think the deepest
purpose or highest purpose of Whole
Foods is and I got an astounding answer
and it wasn't I got answers for all of
them but about 75% of the team members
tell me that Whole Foods is
highest purpose is heroic to to do what
is right and to change and improve the
world and I used to argue with them they
just say no it's not I created whole
food that's not that's not it's not why
we did it it's service it's about love
so service to others no John that's not
what it's about so I had this argument
and then I'd go around all over the
country and finally I surrendered and
said you know what this is a great
example of the enterprise outgrowing its
founder and moving in its own direction
just like a parent raised his children
but eventually the child fulfills its
own destiny oftentimes in a direction
different from what the parents would
aspire to so I've embraced this myself
these are the seven core values of Whole
Foods that are at the center of
everything that we do just real quickly
in terms of those core values selling
the highest quality naps when organic
foods available we're very proud of the
fact that we've been able to improve the
health wellness and longevity of
literally millions of people we've
proven that good health and pleasurable
eating or compatible goals alternatives
to the degradation of an industrial
degradation of our food and we've
educated or beginning to educate our
stakeholders in terms of what healthy
eating is all about how many of you hope
to start your own business someday Wow
great I'm giving you the biggest secret
it's all about the customers you'd be
surprised how few businesses really
understand that and so if you have to
design your business model first and
foremost around the customers because if
you do that
you will probably win because chances
are your competitors will not be as
committed to that as you will be so
they're the most important stakeholder
no customers no business customers
always exchange voluntarily they're not
coerced they trade voluntarily with the
enterprise therefore you have to treat
them as ends and themselves and not as
means we designed our business model at
Whole Foods so that our team members are
completely empowered to do whatever it
takes to satisfy and delight the
customers of course the team members
think they're number one there or
assistant Pointer when I tell them
they're just the number two stakeholder
the customers these are some of the
innovations we've done it
be interesting to go into these in some
detail but for lack of time I'm not self
managing teams on from salary
information of salary cap benefits gain
string for all stock options for all
team members personal wellness accounts
fully paid health insurance and Bill
said we've been naming one about his
company Stuart for for thirteen years in
a row number eighteen in 2010 this is
often times by the time I get to this
part of the presentation people think
this guy's like he's like against
profits he's talking about all this
other stuff but profits are very
important and it's one of the most
important reasons and functions of a
business and that profits are created
through voluntary exchange they are not
primarily created through the
exploitation of people it is not
voluntary exchange that fundamentally
makes business ethical no one is forced
to trade the customers aren't forced to
trade employees aren't forced to trade
suppliers aren't forced to trade
investors aren't forced to invest
everyone invest voluntarily that's what
makes an inherently ethical profits are
they not evil profits are good profits
create wealth they create capital and
they create prosperity capital is the
fuel for all the technological progress
the world has ever known
without that fuel there would be no
progress Whole Foods tried to do its
part we've been the fastest growing a
publicly traded food retailer for the
past ten years eight billion of sales
are themes for sales of hours nine
percent return on invested capital is
thirty five percent
eva'dur compounding a growth rate 30
percent a year since we went public in
1992 our stocks and trees fourteen
hundred percent since her ripe 1992 IPO
even though it traded down tremendously
in nineteen 2007 and 2008 I say one of
the most important functions of
businesses to create prosperity business
has a fundamental responsibility to
create prosperity for society and indeed
for the entire world do you realize that
less than 200 years ago 85 percent of
the people
alive on the planet earth lived on less
than a dollar a day and that's in
today's dollars eighty-five percent
we're down to 20 percent that's progress
that's where business has done that is
what capitalism has done no it's
terrible that we still have over a
billion people on this planet that live
on less than a dollar a day but that's
still only about 20% instead 85% if we
don't screw it up we will end poverty on
the planet Earth in the 21st century
there are people young enough in this
audience today that will live to see
that as Muhammad Yunus says someday
poverty will be something people only
see in museums this is one of the heroic
things that business is doing it is
creating wealth it is creating
prosperity and it is lessening poverty
in the last 15 years Lowe alone in India
in China literally hundreds of millions
of people have been able to escape from
poverty I do not believe suppliers are
supposed to be beaten up I believe their
partners with the business and business
has to create win-win relationships with
their with their suppliers and I'm very
proud of the fact that all these little
tiny ma and Paul suppliers they're all
millionaires now most of them sold out
and sort of sad they sold out to big
corporations but I'm happy they got
wealthy and Whole Foods certainly
contributed that and they contributed to
our success we wouldn't be what we were
today without the growth of our
suppliers I don't know whether you're
aware of it or not but there's a
complete Renaissance going on about
local agriculture in the United States
and it's very exciting Whole Foods is
trying to contribute to that we've made
we have a local loan program we've made
we've loaned about three million dollars
to small producers around the United
States Canada in the UK we're also
trying to work with small poor farmers
around the world our whole trade
guarantee we'd done did over 200 million
dollars in 2009 and whole trade goods we
work with a variety of partners this is
a good thing so I do think that business
has responsibility to be to be
responsible for the communities and
environment and I think that citizenship
is the appropriate metaphor that
business should be good citizens and
whatever communities they do business
and good citizens and their local
communities there are national
communities in the global communities I
think philanthropy is consistent with
citizenship and I also believe that
philanthropy is not theft from the
shareholders it needs to be managed
just as you manage any other part of the
business it needs to be done
intelligently but if done intelligently
it creates a win-win-win strategy that
creates value for all of the
stakeholders including the shareholders
at Whole Foods case we donate a minimum
of five percent of our profits to
not-for-profit organizations 90 percent
of that is done locally in our stores we
support literally thousands and
thousands of not-for-profit
organizations each year we also have a
foundation called the whole planet
foundation this is commitment of our
global citizenship we work with Muhammad
Yunus and the Grameen Bank to make these
microcredit loans we've these are the
country if you currently work in these
are communities that were actually
trading in so we don't just do these
randomly it's wherever our business is
trading in the developing world we look
to eventually set up a microcredit
operation and 98% of our loans have been
to women 98% repayment no collateral no
contracts we've now made over 57,000
loans over ten million dollars and we
just underline Haiti because we just
doubled our commitment to Haiti as a
result of the earthquake and so we're up
to a million dollars now in Haiti and
our microcredit loans eventually we're
going to cover the planet this program
this is an example of win-win
philanthropy when win-win philanthropy
there's no single thing our company has
ever done in our 30-year history that
has created better team member morale
than this so for a mere ten million
dollars we've received hundreds of
millions of dollars of goodwill with our
team member base and with our customers
we've engaged our supply
we call supplier alliances so that
they're also investing in the in the
whole planet foundation which walls give
our customers opportunities to make
contributions Whole Foods cares deeply
about our environment we support local
organic and sustainable agriculture
sustainable seafood is one of the
environmental issues you don't hear much
about which is unfortunate it's a
serious problem we've worked with Marine
Stewardship Council we have farmed fish
standards and we're striving towards
complete transparency for our
sustainability hopefully just one of the
largest companies in the in the world
committed alternative-energy committed
to green building we have store green
mission teams committed animal welfare
standards again environmental strategy
should be thought of as a win-win-win
strategy that benefits all of the
stakeholders we're launching this year
in 2010 our five-step animal welfare
rating program look for that in our
stores we've created a originally this
was a foundation we started ourselves
it's called the animal compassion
foundation we decided we worked with the
animal welfare groups like Humane
Society PETA animal welfare
international we decided to take the
make this a public foundation and
globalize it we won our five step the
animal welfare system we're going to
rather than monopolize low standards
we're giving those standards that we've
created we've worked on it for five
years to create our standards we're
giving those up hopefully for every
everybody everybody else to begin to use
more time I'd go into more detail about
this system no time conscious capitalism
and not-for-profit organizations what
does this have to do with not-for-profit
organizations not-for-profits get one of
the most important aspects of conscious
business they understand the importance
of having a higher purpose and having a
mission that's their gift they had to
teach the for-profit sector however
nonprofits are not able to transcend
self-interest you're not become an angel
just because you work for a non-profit
or work for the government
oftentimes there's anti profit mentality
that severely correct cripples creates
in efficiencies ways and stagnation
therefore many not-for-profit
organizations are not sustainable over
the long run and they need to learn from
corporations about surviving and
flourishing so I argue they need to also
evolve to a more holistic model this is
the model of a conscious nonprofit
organization does it look familiar it
should it looks it's exactly the same as
the conscious enterprise model that I
showed with Whole Foods the only
difference is that at the core you've
got a social mission as opposed to
necessarily a business mission and
instead of investors you have donors
otherwise it's pretty much the same
model this illustrates to me the flaw
and the thinking that many people have
about nonprofits government and
corporations we believe that because
nonprofits have a higher purpose that
they are good they're altruistic they do
all types of wonderful things on the
other side of the wall we have
corporations and they are greedy they
are selfish they only care about profit
I want to tear this wall down this way
of thinking is not going to serve
humanity in the 21st century we've got
to tear this wall down this exaggerated
polarity and dualism between egoism and
altruism is false
human beings are both self-interested
and we're capable of love we don't need
a win-lose metaphor or lose-win metaphor
we need win-win-win metaphors creative
love love of self and love of others is
the golden as Aristotelian mean
it breaks down the economy between ego
isn't altruism you can see that the
upward spiral of caring starts with
yourself move to your family then to
your friends
then to your tribe or your community or
your company potentially moving to your
race or your nation potentially then
expanding on to humanity as a whole
possibly your ability to empathize can
extend to all mammals perhaps even to
all sentient beings and perhaps even to
all life that is the potential that
humanities have humanity has conscious
business is not the same thing as CSR
they are different on the left you see
corporate social responsibility it's
very consistent CSR is very consistent
with the traditional business model it's
consistent because shareholders still
rule instead of stakeholders it has
nothing to do with the corporate purpose
it still has a traditional mechanistic
view of business it's usually an add-on
just an add-on something they'd graft on
to the business we're getting a lot of
stuff about the CSR stuff we can get
some good publicity let's create a CSR
department oftentimes it reports up
through the public relations department
so it's when businesses and corporations
get accused of greenwashing
oftentimes the accusation is correct it
is a simple form of greenwashing whereas
the conscious business social mission
the environmental mission or at the very
essence the very core at the heart of
why the business exists in the first
place
it's not a grafting on instead it's at
the the purpose the center you can meet
the CSR through through a chair a
charitable gesture can meet that but the
conscious business requires a genuine
transformation the CSR assumes that all
good deeds are equally desirable but in
the conscious business the
deeds should correlate back to the
advancing the company's core mission
here's what I want to see happen in the
21st century that we will evolve from
this to this from profit focus to
purpose focus from only shareholding
shareholders winning to all stakeholders
when you from short-term to long-term
from zero sum to win-win-win strategies
from self-centered to holistic from
conflicts of interest to synergies or to
harmony of interests parasitic to
mutualistic from exploitative to
creating value for trade offices
energies from disliked to valued and
loved and from not trusted to trusted
conscious business and conscious
capitalism our new paradigms for the
21st century to just sum it up you have
to support capitalism the conscious
capitalist still supports the key
economic rights that underlie all
capitalism property rights freedom of
contract freedom to trade and the rule
of law the conscious business goes
further identifies a deeper purpose
beyond maximizing profits and
shareholder value the enterprise has
then managed in such a way to create
value simultaneously for all of the
interdependent stakeholders the
leadership becomes conscious to the
enterprise and serves its mission and
its stakeholders we transform the
underlying ethics of the enterprise to a
win-win-win-win philosophy this allows
finally for business and capitalism to
do what human beings want it to do which
is aspire to fulfill the deepest
aspirations that humanity has the good
the true the beautiful and the heroic
thank you very much
all right I did save a little time for
questions I did rapidly go through a lot
of that stuff so how are we doing the
questions or I'm not gonna call them
people or the mics get it passed around
you got the mic scrape so just fire away
thank you so much John as we are mostly
focused on startups around here we get a
lot of founders and entrepreneurs that
come in and a lot of times they speak of
finding a company running it until it
gets to a certain size and then the
investors are bored decide that it'd be
better to have someone perhaps the
industry experience to come in and run
it and now your story is very different
and so I guess from a perspective of a
leadership question while we're are
specific leadership challenges that you
had while your company grew underneath
you you went from being a founder to a
small business owner to you know the CEO
of Whole Foods
well there's 30 years in history there
so I will say that if you start your own
business I came up with a metaphor for
venture capitalists they don't like it
too much but I think it's a pretty good
metaphor
they're like hitchhikers they're
hitchhikers with credit cards and as
long as you get them to where they want
to go they will help pay for the gas
however if you get off track they hijack
the car they hire a new driver and they
throw you out on the side of the road we
never gave a venture capitalist control
of Whole Foods we went public probably a
little earlier than we would have
ordinarily gone because we needed to
raise more capital if we'd done another
round the VCS would have gotten control
of the company so we went ahead and fire
ready aim became public probably you
couldn't even become public as small as
Whole Foods was back in 1992 yeah
wouldn't be possible today in terms of
the challenges there's so many of them I
wouldn't even know where to begin
I will say though that an essence to
your question you have to grow as a
human being and as a leader or you hold
your business back I've been forced to
grow reluctantly at many times because
if I hadn't
the company wasn't going to reach its
full potential so it's essential that
you continue to get not only smarter but
you develop your emotional intelligence
I would say for leadership emotional
intelligence is more important than in
IQ and I would argue that social
intelligence and I would also argue
spiritual intelligence spiritual
intelligence being the ability to
understand purpose and meaning and to be
able to explain that and translate it
are essential intelligences that the
entrepreneurs of the 21st century need
so you're gonna face many challenges as
you grow your business first challenges
of course is money you got to have to
get the money you got to have the
capital so you've got to deal with cash
flow then as you grow you have to be
able to create structures that
simultaneous will allow the business to
fulfill its potential yeah but without
hamstringing it so they have to be
flexible structures that can evolve I
mean if we had if we sat on one on one I
could go over in some detail but there
there are different stages that a
business goes through and different
crises that a business meets and just
like as you go through your own
lifecycle you'll have different crises
when your early 20s it's like finding a
partner and finding work that that's
your crisis when you get into your 30s
you're raising kids you get into you
know 40s and 50s it's starting to be
about generative nests and what your
legacy is gonna be and that's all I've
gotten so far so when I get a little
older I'll find out what the next crisis
is probably body falling apart despite
whole food so it hasn't I don't think
it's made me immortal so I'll deal with
my own problems next question so I'm the
Supreme Court recently came down on the
side of effectively letting corporations
play a more active role in public
political discourse and the liberal wing
of the court I'm over here where are you
there you are so the the liberal wing
the liberal wing of the court made a
distinction between corporate speak and
and individual speak and I was wondering
where you come down on the side of that
debate both in terms of whole foods and
kind of the prevailing business
atmosphere in terms of excuse me weather
that new opportunity may be used more
opportunistically by others than it
might be by Whole Foods you know every
time I ever take on a political question
I get totally slammed in the media so on
the other hand I aspire to authenticity
so what am I supposed to do let me try
to be cagey on this one inauthentic I
don't believe that media corporations
such as the New York Times in the Wall
Street Journal and Forbes that they
should have the right for freedom of
speech because they own media assets and
other corporations therefore don't
because they don't know a medium and
media assets so as a general rule I
don't think corporations are eager to
you pay a price when you speak out
publicly I trust me I found that out
this summer so I don't think this ruling
I do think it's consistent with freedom
of speech and I I I was happy with the
ruling
so mostly because I don't think it's
going to be all the negative things that
people believe is gonna happen it's
gonna happen but time will tell
next question so you might have to be
cagey again here I don't want to talk
about climate change or healthcare
reform okay
so I don't necessarily agree with this
argument but I want to see how you
respond to the argument why not simply
have government enforce the conscious
capitalism that you're advocating for
whether that be you know subsidizing
green projects or health care reform or
whatnot well because I might be wrong I
mean people believe that if they had
ultimate power they would be good and I
don't believe in a society where
government is is legislating a
particular vision on the way people
should live even if I happen to be my
vision I believe in a in a pluralistic
society where we get to experiment
and that one of the secrets to Whole
Foods is we're very experimental company
we try things most of them fail but we
throw out the failures and we continue
to learn and evolve so I believe in a
society that's it's democratic and
allows I believe conscious capitalism by
the way is going to triumph at the end
of 21st century
why not because government has to pass
the laws to force people to be that way
because it works better it's going to
win in the marketplace it's going to win
in competition so these ideas need to be
tried out and if they work they'll
they'll flourish and expand if they
don't work they'll be thrown in the
trash bin of history and having
government pick winners for business
philosophies is a very bad idea
first of all because they probably won't
pick the ideas that you agree with
anyway so I don't want to live in a
society where government is telling us
how businesses should operate I think
that the marketplace should determine
that
hi can you talk about some of the
difficult decisions you've had to make
with your supply chain when you as Whole
Foods has grown over the past 20 years
could you give me a little more color on
that I mean what in terms of maintaining
the integrity of what you wanted in a
supplier when you first started the
business versus what you can get as
you've scaled to be such a large company
the first crisis of faith at Whole Foods
was when we realized our suppliers were
mostly weren't - they they weren't as
good as their marketing materials
indicated that's the disillusionment of
a retailer because as we got in there
and looked beneath the kimono so to
speak a lot of what we saw was not that
pretty
for example in the meat industry if you
really knew what they were doing or
those animals out there you probably all
become vegetarians or vegans it's
terrible and it's we've gotten into the
process and we've seen more so that's
the first challenge is the retailer's
the middleman right between the farmer
the rancher the manufacturer and the
consumer and the consumer trusts us too
to deliver what the manufacturer claims
they blame us if it's not so that was
the first challenge that we had and it's
an ongoing challenge we have to we have
to look very deeply at our supply chain
and determine whether or not it's it's
what it's cracked up to be
that it and so we're doing lots of
things now like we have our animal
welfare rating system we're going to put
all of our every body we'd buy meat from
which is thousands and thousands of
people we'll have to get every we'll
have to get rated in terms of the way
they treat their animals so we can give
transparency to our customers seafood
sustainability is another one that is
very important and people are not aware
that so many of the species they buy and
seafood departments are not sustainable
and yet the retailer's are not telling
the customers ask so they're not they're
keeping that as a secret so we're gonna
we're gonna basically be much more
transparent about that there's all kinds
of the first organic supply or Whole
Foods bought from for example
anecdotally here was a company in
Southern California it was called
sunburst farms and you read their
marketing materials are organic there's
this community living there and it looks
like they're love and peace and joy and
it seems like a really wonderful thing
we checked we got into it we checked him
out and turns out they were like the guy
that was it was a cult leader and they
were survival this group that had a
whole bunch they were they were stocking
up guns for Armageddon that was coming
and in fact they weren't selling that
much organic produce it was mostly they
were taking they had organic boxes and
they were taking commercial produce and
sticking in the organic boxes and
shipping it out so there was a lot of
fraud that we had to deal with now we're
in this enviable position I suppose that
we've gotten large enough where we can
go work with our suppliers in a more
transparent way to assure ourselves and
our customers that the people are really
getting what they've been promised so if
you're smaller it's a lot harder to do
that so there is fraud that goes on in
business I'm sorry to say and
so that was one of our challenges we had
to deal with that's next question John
off here to your right Stan great
originally uh my family's been Whole
Foods shoppers for 20 years so we're big
fans and I also was a former front-end
team leader at your Richardson Texas
store so look how far you there so we
made it all the way so big fans thanks
for your time question for you about 10
to 15 years ago it seemed like there was
a shift from Whole Foods started
stocking Lay's potato chips some
conventional items and it seemed like
there might have been a shift in you
know the culture or the core business
segment you guys were going after and
then a few years later went back and
eliminated those products and focus more
on organics just trying to figure out
what kind of thinking was at the company
at that two-year period and then kind of
where you guys went from there well you
can't understand Whole Foods unless you
understand how decentralized and
empowered we are that was not a decision
that was made in Austin Texas for the
whole company that was probably made
locally in a store or a region and it
was done as an experiment so experiment
was taking went out and customers didn't
like it and experiment was just a
failure but that was a I was not a
company-wide experiment so again most of
our experiments they must have fail but
and that was one I would argue that that
that that failed but it was important
that the region and the store get a
chance to test that idea out it might be
disillusioning but again most of the
suppliers that were in the early days
they've mostly sold out to - like
PepsiCo frito-lay coca-cola Kraft
General Foods most of natural food
labels now and in the hands of those
larger food manufacturers and there's
less transparency there than there
should be and Whole Foods of course has
got a much greater commitment to our
private label now at this point Trader
Joe's is like 85 90 % private label and
the Whole Foods is only about 20% so I
don't think there was any lasting
cultural change but there is continued
evolution in the supply chain that we
have to deal with I don't
perhaps Leonard green in Whole Foods in
2008 now you came to the decision to
take private equity capital and how that
partnership has a business to evolve
over the last year a good question
we bought the Wild Oats merger has
worked out extremely well for us but the
timing of it was terrible when we of
course then we gotten a whole FTC thing
and what a hassle that was and how much
money we wasted on that but another
story but when we bought Wild Oats the
market we were kind of at our peak stock
price we paid cash for him in order to
do that we had to go borrow money so we
took on a lot of debt more debt than
we'd ever taken on our company's history
but we didn't think it being a big deal
because we thought we would we'd sell
stock in a couple of months and pay off
pay down the debt but then our the
economy started going into the tank
first of all that the merger got put off
many many months while I had to go
through the regulatory processes then
then our stock started to decline
because the economy was declining and
our sales were declining so we didn't
want to sell stock and then what
September 2008 you can remember that
time I've never that was a panic that's
the only panic I'm old enough to live
through and I'm probably the oldest guy
in the room so it's a everything went to
hell and our sales started plummeting
our stock went down to $7 we were
trading at two times our cash flow could
have bought Whole Foods and got a 50%
return on cash flow alone I was banking
please let me buy back stock please let
me buy back stock but the board in their
infinite wisdom realized that what if
it's not the bottom what if it's not the
bottom what if it gets worse and so that
was a good point of view and we're sweet
we took the money in from wintergreen as
an insurance policy it's what it was it
was an insurance policy and the event
Armageddon was really happening we
wanted to survive and it turns out we
didn't actually need the capital
Armageddon did not happen deepest
recession in my lifetime happened but
not Armageddon but you know what Leonard
Green has been a great great investor
they owned 17% of the company and they
don't control it but they've been very
valuable on the board they do take a
long-term perspective they love us
I guess because we've already made like
five hundred million dollars form in the
year so one of my jokes is is that when
the stock is up I'm this visionary and
when the stock is down I'm like the
village idiot
your reputation waxes and wanes based on
that on the stock price but with Leonard
Greene I'm visionary because they've
made so much money so glad we did it it
was insurance policy then I'm glad we
didn't have to collect on how is that
and I would but I think they are here
lots of bad things about private equity
firms Leonard Green is an outstanding
firm with great integrity I'm proud to
be associated with them hope that gets
printed in the newspaper thanks very
much